Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. We were amazed and said that it was like the enchantments they tell of in the legend of Amardis, on account of the great towers and the temples and the buildings rising from the water, and all of it built of masonry. And some of our soldiers asked whether the things that we saw were not a dream. That was the conquistador Bernal Díaz, remembering the initial site of the great Aztec city, Tenochtitlan, on the 8th of November 1519, the date on which the Spanish first saw the great Aztec capital. And Dominic, it's one of the kind of the most romantic and dramatic moments in the whole world history, isn't it?
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客内容、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及深受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们当时感到震惊，并说这就像阿玛迪斯传奇中所讲述的魔法一样，因为那些高耸的塔楼、寺庙和从水面升起的建筑，全部都是由砖石建造的。我们的一些士兵甚至在问，我们眼前看到的这一切是不是一场梦。这是征服者贝尔纳·迪亚斯（Bernal Díaz）在1519年11月8日对阿兹特克伟大城市特诺奇蒂特兰最初选址的回忆，这也是西班牙人首次见到这座宏伟阿兹特克首都的日子。多米尼克，这是世界历史上最浪漫、最具戏剧性的时刻之一，对吧？
Are you a fan of the drama of this great story? Tom, that's exactly the word I was going to use, romantic. I remember having this book as a, I don't know, about a seven or eight year old, as a seven or eight year old boy. And this, the men with feathered headdresses, bloody knives, human sacrifice, the sort of Spanish storming in the Aztecs thinking they were gods. You know, all the sort of stereotypes of the Aztec story as we've read them, as we read about it in Britain. And the Aztecs thinking that the end of the world was coming. Yeah, it's that apocalypto, isn't it? Okay. I imagine this book was probably written by Mel gibson in a sort of as a very young man maybe um i'm not sure he knows the difference between
你是这个伟大故事中戏剧冲突的粉丝吗？汤姆，这正是我打算用的词——浪漫。我还记得自己大概七八岁的时候，读过这本书，作为七八岁的小男孩。书中那些戴着羽毛头饰的人、血淋淋的刀子、人祭，还有西班牙人冲进来、阿兹特克人把他们当成神明的情形。你知道，正如我们在英国读到的那样，关于阿兹特克故事的各种刻板印象。阿兹特克人当时以为世界末日要来临了。是的，就是那种“启示录”式的场景，对吧？好吧。我想这本书大概是梅尔·吉布森在很年轻的时候写的吧，嗯，我不确定他是否分得清
the aztecs and the mayas but that's a whole different issue well it is one of the the great stories but it is also a story that we perhaps particularly in europe tend to see through the eyes of the spanish and of course the the aztecs are one of the most remarkable, one of the most creative civilizations that ever existed. But it's hard for us, I think, to see them as they saw themselves. And so that's why I'm massively excited that our very first transatlantic guest, our first American guest on the show, we have Camilla Townsend, whose book came out last year, Fifth Son, A New History of the Aztecs, was absolutely the best book that I read last year. I read it kind of just before Christmas.
阿兹特克人和玛雅人，但这完全是另一个问题了。好吧，这确实是那些伟大的故事之一，但这也是一个我们（或许特别是在欧洲）倾向于通过西班牙人的视角来看待的故事。当然，阿兹特克人是最卓越、最有创造力的文明之一。但对我们来说，要想真正以他们自己的视角去理解他们是很困难的。正因如此，我极其兴奋地迎来了我们的第一位跨大西洋嘉宾、节目历史上的首位美国嘉宾——卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）。她去年出版的书《第五个太阳：阿兹特克人的新历史》（Fifth Son, A New History of the Aztecs）绝对是我去年读过最好的书。我是圣诞节前不久读的。
And I was kind of doing my best books of the year list. And honestly, if I'd read it by the time I was doing the list, I would have, it would have been number one across it. And the thing that's brilliant about it is that it gives you a history of the Aztecs through Aztec eyes insofar as that is possible. So Camilla, thanks so much for coming on. Absolutely delighted that you've agreed to come and join us and talk to us about the Aztecs. Oh, thank you so much. The honour really is mine. I'm delighted to be here. So Dominic and I gave a perhaps not entirely accurate account of the Spanish conquest there. Just very briefly, I mean, in your book, you cover the whole span of Aztec history, but there were two myths there that I think we hit on. One is that the Aztecs thought that the
当时我正在列我心目中的年度好书榜单。老实说，如果我在做榜单的时候已经读过它，它绝对会高居榜首。这本书最棒的地方在于，它尽可能地通过阿兹特克人的视角为你呈现了一部阿兹特克历史。卡米拉，非常感谢你能来。非常高兴你能应邀加入我们，和我们一起聊聊阿兹特克人。哦，非常感谢。真正的荣誉其实是属于我的。很高兴能来到这里。所以，我和多米尼克刚才对西班牙征服的描述可能并非完全准确。简而言之，在你的书中，你涵盖了阿兹特克历史的全貌，但其中有我们碰巧涉及的两个神话。一个是阿兹特克人认为
Spanish were gods, and the other was that they thought that with the Spanish conquest, the end of the world was happening. And you demonstrate pretty conclusively that neither of those were true. Right. You have hit very much on the sort of stereotypical view of their history, as it's told not only in Europe, but here in the United States, and to some extent, even in Mexico as well. The truth was, I would say, both more mundane and more spectacular. They were originally people from what is today the American Southwest. They share common ancestors with people that are famous here, like the Hopi. And they came down over the course of a couple hundred years, a little bit like Genghis Khan coming down into China.
西班牙人是神，另一个是他们认为随着西班牙征服的到来，世界末日正在发生。而你相当确凿地证明了这两点都不是真的。没错。你们非常精准地切中了他们历史的刻板印象，这种印象不仅在欧洲流传，在美国也是如此，在某种程度上甚至在墨西哥也存在。事实是，我想说，既更世俗又更壮观。他们最初来自今天的美国西南部。他们与这里著名的民族（如霍皮族）拥有共同的祖先。他们经过几百年的时间南下，有点像成吉思汗南下进入中国那样。
And gradually, these Nahuatl-speaking people, Aztec-language-speaking people, took over the central valley of Mexico. There had been great high civilizations farming peoples there before, but these guys were conquerors, and they took over the valley. They had been the rulers par excellence, the most powerful guys in Mexico, for about 100 years when the Spaniards arrived. And they put up a fight. There is no evidence that they actually thought Cortes or anyone with him was a god. There was quite a war. It was a really tough urban combat. Well, the whole war took a couple of years, but within the city, a couple of months.
这些说纳瓦特尔语、说阿兹特克语的人逐渐接管了墨西哥中央谷地。在那之前，那里曾有过伟大的高度文明和农耕民族，但这些人是征服者，他们占领了谷地。当西班牙人抵达时，他们作为统治者中的佼佼者、墨西哥最有权势的人，已经统治了大约100年。他们进行了反抗。没有任何证据表明他们真的认为科尔特斯或随行的任何人是神。那是一场相当激烈的战争。那是一场非常残酷的城市巷战。好吧，整场战争持续了几年，但在城市内部则持续了几个月。
Many died. The diseases that the Europeans brought with them helped, although they were not the defining factor. And then after this conquest, the Spaniards continued to rely on the Aztecs. They ruled through them, in effect. The famous Spanish Empire that we hear so much about and its home base in Mexico depended very much on their ability to work with the Aztecs and have the Aztec leaders help them to establish control. So the Aztecs, the people that Tom and I know as the Aztecs, but you would call it the Mexica, they've come from somewhere else. So they've come from what is now the United States, right? So when we
许多人死亡。欧洲人带来的疾病起到了推导作用，尽管它们并不是决定性因素。征服之后，西班牙人继续依赖阿兹特克人。实际上，他们通过阿兹特克人进行统治。我们经常听说的那个著名的西班牙帝国及其在墨西哥的大本营，在很大程度上取决于他们与阿兹特克人合作的能力，以及借助阿兹特克领袖来帮助他们建立控制。所以，阿兹特克人——汤姆和我所知道的阿兹特克人，但你可能会称之为墨西卡人（Mexica）——他们来自其他地方。所以他们来自现在的美国，对吧？所以当我们
talk about them as indigenous, I mean, that's quite a slippery term because they're migrants, invaders themselves, as the Spanish were. They were migrant invaders, although it was their ancestors. That is, the people that Cortés and his fellows met had been living there then. They'd been living on the island where they were for 100 years, and they had been in that area for a couple hundred years. But their ancestors, their immediate ancestors, were migrants from what is today the United States. And those people were migrants from further north.
把他们称为原住民时，这个词其实挺滑头的，因为他们和西班牙人一样，也是移民和侵略者。他们是移民侵略者，尽管那是他们的祖先。也就是说，科尔特斯及其同伴遇到的人当时已经在那里生活了。他们已经在他们所在的岛屿上生活了100年，并且在该地区生活了数百年。但他们的祖先，即他们的直系祖先，是从今天的美国迁徙而来的。而那些人则是从更北方迁徙来的。
That is, it was Asian peoples who came across the Bering Strait. There was a land bridge at the time during the Ice Ages. They came in at least three major waves. So there has been some political discussion of that here in the United States. Well, we say these people are indigenous, but in fact, they originally came from Asia. But I think when people have been present for at least 10,000 years longer than any Europeans who have ever touched foot on the land, we can say that they are indigenous. And Camilla, the story of how the Aztecs and Mexica come to what is now Central Mexico, we know this because the descendants of the Aztecs wrote this down? I mean...
也就是说，那是穿过白令海峡的亚洲人群。在冰河时期，当时有一座陆桥。他们至少分三波主要浪潮涌入。所以美国国内对此也有过一些政治讨论。好吧，我们说这些人是原住民，但事实上，他们最初来自亚洲。不过我认为，当人们在一片土地上生活的时间，比任何踏上这片土地的欧洲人都要长至少一万年时，我们就可以说他们是原住民。卡米拉，阿兹特克人和墨西卡人如何来到现在的墨西哥中部，我们知道这一点是因为阿兹特克人的后代把这些记录下来了吗？我的意思是……
Yes. Well, we know it in three ways. Archaeologists look at pottery, etc., styles of remnants of their civilization, and they can tell which culture went where by roughly when. We know it because the linguists help us, people who study historical linguistics. They're the ones who have shown how many waves of migrants came. And then we mostly know it in the details that we know it, because the Nawaz or the people who spoke Nawat, the Aztecs, they did write down their histories. They wrote them down in pictoglyphs before the Europeans arrived. And after the Europeans arrived, they took the Roman alphabet that they had been taught so that they could read the Bible. And they went home, these young scholars, young students went home and spoke to their uncles and grandfathers and grandmothers and said, please tell me the history or tell me the prayer, tell me the story that you used to tell. And they wrote it, they sounded it out, they transcribed it, they wrote it down using the Roman alphabet, but in their own language.
是的。嗯，我们通过三种方式得知。考古学家通过陶器等遗物以及文明残余的风格进行研究，他们大致能根据时间判断出哪个文化去过哪里。我们通过语言学家的帮助得知，也就是研究历史语言学的人。正是他们展示了移民分成了多少波。然后，我们之所以能了解这么多的细节，主要是因为纳瓦人（Nawaz）或说纳瓦特尔语的人、即阿兹特克人，他们确实写下了自己的历史。在欧洲人到达之前，他们用象形文字记录下来。欧洲人到达后，他们学会了被教导的罗马字母，以便阅读《圣经》。这些年轻的学者、年轻的学生回到家，跟他们的叔叔、爷爷和奶奶说，请告诉我历史，或者告诉我你过去常讲的祈祷文、故事。他们把它们写下来，按读音拼写，用罗马字母转写下来，但用的是他们自己的语言。
So if we study Nahuatl, and I have studied Nahuatl for more than 20 years now, we can read these full-throated expressions, complex stories, poems, even some religious utterings, etc. revelatory, but also so moving. Because if you study Roman history, basically what you know about the Gauls or the Germans comes from Roman writers, and you can match it up perhaps with archaeology or whatever, but you don't have Gallic accounts of Caesar's conquest. You don't have the Germans saying where they thought they came from. But kind of with this, suddenly, people who've been conquered and who essentially, you know, their identity has long been suppressed, are being given a voice in your book. And it's incredibly moving and powerful to hear them speak. You know, I think what has grabbed you, what you have found compelling is really the same element that grabbed me or that I found compelling. That is, it's almost as if
因此，如果我们研究纳瓦特尔语——我现在已经研究纳瓦特尔语20多年了——我们就能读到这些饱满的表达、复杂的叙事、诗歌，甚至一些宗教言论等。这既具有启示性，又非常感人。因为如果你研究罗马历史，基本上你对高卢人或日耳曼人的了解都来自于罗马作家，你或许可以将其与考古学或其他证据结合起来，但你并没有高卢人对凯撒征服的记述。你没有日耳曼人讲述他们认为自己来自哪里的说法。然而有了这些，突然之间，那些被征服的人、那些本质上身份长期被压抑的人，在你的书中发出了声音。听到他们开口说话，是极其感人和充满力量的。你知道，我认为打动你的、让你觉得引人入胜的元素，实际上和打动我、让我觉得引人入胜的元素是一样的。也就是说，这几乎就像
we're parachuting in to some remarkable situation that, as you say, has existed in other times and places, but usually is so buried over in the layers of time and writing that we don't have direct access or a direct window to it. But these people who had not been sedentary for very long, who were farmers, but still were also partly hunters, who were still living in some very ancient ways, were there in the 1500s, learned to write and wrote all sorts of things about how, you know, all sorts of stories that we now can read and hence listen to in a way that, as you say, we can't do for the Gauls or even for the ancient Britons.
我们空降到一个非凡的情境中。正如你所说，这种情境在其他时代和地方也存在过，但通常被埋没在层层的时间与文字之下，以至于我们无法直接接触它，也没有直接的窗口。然而，这些定居时间并不长、既是农民但同时也部分保留猎人身份、依然以某些非常古老的方式生活着的人，在1500年代就在那里了，他们学会了写作，并写下了各种各样关于……你知道的，各种各样我们现在可以阅读的故事，从而以一种你所说的那样无法为高卢人甚至古代不列颠人做到的方式，倾听他们的声音。
It's really quite remarkable, the clash of difference that one is able to see, and yet the commonalities too, between people who have been sedentary for millennia and those who haven't. So it's fascinating, yes. Camilla, before we come back to the conquest and their reactions to the conquest, I just wanted to ask a question because we've had tons of questions from listeners about their own sense of their past. So they've made this journey and they've come to the Central Valley in Mexico. And one of our listeners, Joshua Terry, has asked how much are they aware of preceding cultures like
能够看到不同文明之间的冲突，同时又能看到那些定居了数千年的人与未定居的人之间的共同点，这真的是非常了不起的。所以这很迷人，是的。卡米拉，在我们回到征服以及他们对征服的反应之前，我只想问一个问题，因为我们收到了大量听众关于他们对自己过去的认知的提问。他们完成了这段旅程，来到了墨西哥的中央谷地。我们的一位听众约书亚·特里（Joshua Terry）问，他们对前人文化（比如
the Olmec or the Maya. A list called Pharaoh Man has asked about the Toltecs. So how much do they have a sense of themselves as the, how much are they a break? And how much are they the heirs to previous sort of Mesoamerican civilizations? The Aztecs are fascinating because they see themselves both as chichimeca, meaning sort of savage people, wild people, people with bows and arrows, tough guys, okay, who came down from the north, but also the heirs of the people who have been living as high culture, civilized farmers in central Mexico for centuries. And that is because they intermarried with them. These were mostly male or even in some cases,
奥尔梅克人或玛雅人）了解多少？一个叫法老男（Pharaoh Man）的听众问到了托尔特克人。那么，他们对自己作为继承者的感知有多少？他们与过去有多少断裂？他们能在多大程度上算是前美索不达米亚文明的继承者？阿兹特克人很迷人，因为他们既视自己为“奇奇梅卡”（Chichimeca），意为野蛮人、野人、拿着弓箭的人、硬汉——好吧，是从北方南下的人，同时也视自己为几个世纪以来在墨西哥中部作为高文化、文明农民生活的人的继承者。这是因为他们与这些人通婚了。这些大多是男性，甚至在某些情况下，
all male groups that were on the move rapidly, making war, moving to the south. And everywhere they went, they intermarried with and became acculturated with the people who lived where they were arriving. So they felt themselves to be the heirs of both. And in their writings, you see them take great pride in being Toltecs, artists, people of the valley, and also Chichimecs, savage warriors. They like both halves of themselves. Is it a bit like Anglo-Saxons or Franks going to Rome and feeling both they are barbarians, but they are also the heirs of this remarkable city? I do think so. I think that's a very good analogy, right, and feeling truly proud of both sides. Because the Aztec kings would go on pilgrimage, wouldn't they, to Teotihuacan,
是全由男性组成、处于快速移动中、四处征战并向南迁移的群体。他们走到哪里，就与哪里的人通婚并逐渐融入当地。因此，他们觉得自己既是两者的继承者。在他们的著作中，你会发现他们为自己既是托尔特克人、艺术家、谷地人，又是奇奇梅克人、野蛮战士而感到巨大的骄傲。这有点像盎格鲁-撒克逊人或法兰克人去到罗马，既觉得自己是野蛮人，但同时也是这座了不起城市的继承者吗？我的确这么认为。我认为这是一个非常好的比喻，对吧，并为这两个方面都感到由衷的自豪。因为阿兹特克国王会去朝圣，不是吗，去特奥蒂瓦坎（Teotihuacan），
which is this kind of, I mean, it was built at the same time as ancient Rome, isn't it? It's first millennium AD. I mean, this kind of astonishing pyramids and then abandoned for mysterious reasons. The most remarkable preceding culture was definitely Teotihuacan, which is actually a Nahuatl, Aztec word, sort of place where gods come into being, in effect. And we still know it by the Aztec word, because we don't know what language the people who actually lived there even spoke. It may have been a related language. That is, they too may have spoken a language that had come from what is now the American Southwest, but we can't be certain. And so the Aztecs clearly were very much aware of this place. It had fallen into decline mysteriously, as Tom has said, before they arrived, but the archaeological remains were still so large and so impressive that it was almost a tourist site, if you can use that word anachronistically. I guess pilgrimage, your word is better, Tom. They would make pilgrimages.
这是一个……我的意思是，它与古罗马建于同一时期，对吧？公元第一个千年。我是说，这里有令人惊叹的金字塔，然后由于神秘的原因被废弃了。最引人注目的前人文化绝对是特奥蒂瓦坎，这实际上是一个纳瓦特尔语、阿兹特克语词汇，大意是“神明诞生的地方”。我们至今仍用这个阿兹特克词来称呼它，因为我们甚至不知道实际生活在那里的人说的是什么语言。那可能是一种相关的语言。也就是说，他们说的可能也是一种源自现在美国西南部的语言，但我们无法确定。因此，阿兹特克人显然非常清楚这个地方。正如汤姆所说，在他们到达之前，它已经神秘地衰落了，但考古遗迹依然如此巨大和震撼，以至于如果你不合时宜地使用这个词的话，它几乎就像一个旅游景点。我想朝圣，你的词更好，汤姆。他们会去朝圣。
Because it's holy. I guess it's kind of holy, isn't it? Yes. Oh, absolutely. Kind of ghost haunted. And they placed their own origin myth right there. That is, they said this is where it all began. They also knew that they came as humans down from the north. Those real stories, real histories were still present in their minds. But when they told the story of the beginning of this fifth age, the
因为它是神圣的。我想它有点神圣，对吧？是的。哦，绝对的。带着一种鬼魅般的色彩。他们把自己的起源神话就放在那里。也就是说，他们说这一切都是从这里开始的。他们也知道自己作为人类是从北方南下的。那些真实的故事、真实的叙事仍然存在于他们的记忆中。但当他们讲述这个第五个时代的开始时，
fifth son, my book title is The Fifth Son, they felt that we were living under the fifth son, and they felt that that son had been born at this incredibly miraculous place in the heart of the Valley of Mexico. And what do the guys, what do the people who live roundabout think of them? Do they think of them as intruders, as bullies, as what? You know, it's complicated. On one level, yes, the Aztecs were intruders and bullies. And, you know, the indigenous people in Mexico are famous for having allied with Cortes when he arrived. On the other hand, the Aztecs were very good at sort of working with the people that they were conquering and intermixing with. And they intermarried with the royal houses, the noble lineages of many different surrounding communities. So the people in the very heart of the Central
即“第五个太阳”——我的书名就叫《第五个太阳》，他们觉得我们是生活在第五个太阳之下，而且他们觉得这个太阳诞生在墨西哥谷地中心这个极其神奇的地方。那么周围的人、住在附近的人是怎么看他们的呢？他们把他们视为入侵者、恶霸，还是什么？你知道，情况很复杂。从某种程度上讲，是的，阿兹特克人是入侵者和恶霸。而且，你知道，墨西哥的原住民以在科尔特斯抵达时与他结盟而闻名。另一方面，阿兹特克人非常擅长与他们正在征服和通婚的人进行合作。他们与许多不同周边社群的王室、贵族血统进行了通婚。所以，位于中央谷地最核心、生活在大湖周围的人——阿兹特克人就住在座大湖中间的一个岛上——他们中的许多人觉得，他们是一个我们或许可以称之为“国家”、一个伟大政府的一部分，其中许多人在议会中拥有发言权。所以，周围的所有原住民都痛恨阿兹特克人，这并不是真的。但你离得越远，被征服的人就会感到越深。毫无疑问，他们中的一些人非常乐意与西班牙人结盟。你提到了关于第五个时代如何开始的神话。我们收到了EKG的一个问题：他们的宇宙观是什么样的？他们是如何看待太阳、月亮和星星的？还有，把范围扩大一点。我的意思是，你得先理解他们是如何看待宇宙的，我想，
Valley who lived around the Great Lake, the Aztecs lived on an island in the middle of this Great Lake. Many of them felt that they were part and parcel of a sort of a state, we might say, of a great government, and many of them had voices in the council. So it really isn't true that all indigenous people all around hated the Aztecs. But the further away you got, the more conquered people felt. And there's no question that some of them were only too happy to ally with the Spaniards. You mentioned about the myth of how the Fifth Age begins. So we've got a question from EKG. What does their cosmos look like? How do they think of the sun, moon, and stars? But also broadening that out. I mean, you need to kind of understand how they see the cosmos, I guess,
才能理解他们的文明。那么，他们与这座伟大的废弃城市联系在一起的神话是什么？那里到底发生了什么？他们觉得他们的直系祖先是一个名叫纳纳瓦岑（Nanahuatzin）的人。第四个时代、即第四个太阳相当灾难性地内爆了。人类和所有生灵——神明、人类、动物，那些仅存的幸存者——生活在绝对的黑暗之中。神明们走来说：“我们需要一个勇敢而伟大的存在跳进火里。一个新的太阳将从中诞生。”从那以后，一个非常自恋的家伙站出来说：“我来做。”神明们说：“好，还有别人吗？”没有人愿意自愿承担这项可怕的任务。但最终，其中一位神明说：“好吧，我们需要后备人选。”于是，他们选择了纳纳瓦岑，一个相当卑微、并不想这么做的家伙。他不想死，但他心里想：
to understand their civilization. So what is the myth that they identify with this kind of great abandoned city? What is it that happens there? They felt that their direct ancestor was a guy named Nanahuatzin. And that the fourth age, the fourth son had imploded rather disastrously. And people and all beings, divine human animals, those few that survived were living in utter darkness. And the gods came and said, we need a brave and great being to jump into a fire. And from that will emerge a new sun. From thatcio, a guy with a lot of self-love stepped forward and said, I will do it. And the gods said, okay, is there anybody else? And nobody else wanted to volunteer for such a terrible task. But eventually, one of the gods said, well, we need backup. So, they chose Nanahuatzin, a rather humble guy who didn't want to do it. He didn't want to die, but he thought to himself,
好吧，神明对我不薄。毕竟，我都熬过了可怕的时光，活到了今天。我需要回应这个呼唤，我需要做该做的事。于是他答应了。神明给那个自负的家伙穿上了华丽的服装，却只给他们精心挑选的替补戴上了一顶小纸冠。嗯，然后，当然，正如你所料，当时机到来时，那位伟大的英雄发现自己无论如何也无法跳进火里自焚。他试了又试，就是做不到。于是，神明们转过身，凝视着阿兹特克的祖先纳纳瓦岑，他其实也不想去。但他闭上眼睛，做了他必须做的事。他很勇敢。当然，从那以后，
well, the gods have been good to me. After all, I've survived horrible times. Here I am. I need to respond to the call. I need to do what needs doing. So he agreed. And they gave a great costume to the vainglorious guy, and they gave just a little paper crown to the understudy that they had handpicked. Well, then, of course, as you might imagine, when the time came, the great hero could not find it in himself to jump into the fire and burn himself to death. He tried, he tried, he couldn't do it. So, the gods turned and stared at Nanahuatzin, the Aztec's ancestor, and he didn't want to do it. But he closed his eyes and did what he had to do. He was brave. And of course, from that,
你知道，他牺牲了自己，但太阳诞生了，人们从此世世代代繁衍生息。这确实很能代表他们看待自己的方式。也就是说，他们把自己视为经历过绝望时光、并找到勇气去做必须做的事情的相当卑微的人。他们实际上是最后一批到达的人。所有那些从后来成为美国的地方南下的各路人群，他们是最后一批到达的，几乎就像最后一拨挤进拥挤地区的移民。因此，他们视自己为经历过艰难困苦、不得不咬牙坚持的人。而他们活了下来。
you know, he's immolated, but the son is born and the people live forever after. So that really is quite emblematic of the way that they thought about themselves. That is, they thought of themselves as rather humble folk who had lived through desperate times and found the courage to do what needed to be done. They were the last arrivals, actually. All those streams of people who came down from what will later be the United States, they were the last to arrive, almost like the last group of immigrants to arrive in a crowded area. And so they saw themselves as having been through tough times, having had to be the scrappy guys. And they had survived.
他们为之自豪。他们建造了这座不可思议的城市。我的意思是，我读过西班牙人的记载，你写的那份记载：一个极其美丽的城市，到处都是有闲暇时间和精力写诗、制作芳香巧克力饮料、有时还探讨道德问题的公民。他们的权力不断增长。他们最初之所以在那个岛上落脚，是因为别人都嫌弃那里。那是沼泽地，无法种植玉米和豆类。但他们从那个岛上、从泥土中硬是培育出了庄稼，然后参与了战争。他们在建立的同盟关系上非常聪明、极具战略眼光，
They were proud of that. And they create this incredible city. I mean, I read the Spanish account, your one, a gloriously beautiful city filled with citizens who had the leisure time and energy to write poetry, create aromatic chocolate drinks, and sometimes debate morality. They grew in power. They had started on that island because nobody else wanted it. It was marshy ground. You couldn't plant corn and beans. But they coaxed some crops from that island, from the earth, and then they took part in wars. They were very clever, very strategic about the alliances that they formed,
在防止不同妻子、不同王室分支的后代开始自相残杀方面做得很好。于是，他们一点一点地占领了整个谷地。事实上，他们身处岛上对他们很有帮助，因为他们可以在那里建立一个大型集市，并通过独木舟交通将散落在大湖四周的村庄紧密联系起来。这有点类似于古代地中海历史。我们都知道地中海促进了商业贸易的增长。或者说威尼斯，我想。我的意思是，西班牙人确实把它比作威尼斯，不是吗？完全正确。所以，当你位于某种海域的边缘时，你就能触及更多的领土。
very good about not allowing different branches of the royal family born of different women, different wives, to start fighting with each other. And so little by little, they took over the whole valley. It helped, actually, it turned out that they were on an island because they could set up a big marketplace there and through canoe traffic could tie together villages scattered all around the edge. It's a bit comparable to ancient Mediterranean history. We all know that the Mediterranean helped merchant aid grow. Or Venice, I guess. I mean, Spanish do compare it to Venice, don't they? Exactly. Right. So you can reach more territory when you're on the edge of some sort of a sea.
因此，凭借他们的中心位置以及聪明的政治手腕，他们变得极其强大。与其他强大、富有的文明一样，他们开始做伟大的事，也开始做可怕的事。你知道，他们写诗、发明了热巧克力，但他们也痛击帝国边缘的小部落，并把这些战争中的失败者带回家进行献祭。如果是发明了热巧克力，那倒还可以原谅。我想事实确实如此。但我能问一个关于这座城市的问题吗？如果——我的意思是，我们显然对西班牙人的记载有一定了解，但如果我们审视特诺奇蒂特兰，我们会看到什么？
So they, with their central location and then their clever politicking, rose to be extremely powerful. And like other powerful, rich civilizations, they started to do both great and terrible things. You know, they wrote poetry, they invented hot chocolate, but they also beat up little people around the edges of their empire and brought losers in these wars home for sacrifice. If invented hot chocolate, you can get away with it. I suppose that is indeed the case. But can I ask a question about the city? So if, I mean, we obviously must have a sense from the Spanish accounts, but if we looked at Tenochtitlan and we, what would we see?
或者我们会听到什么、闻到什么？你认为最引人注目的会是什么？嗯，从中心看下去，或者从水面上、从大陆海岸眺望这座城市，你会看到两座宏伟的寺庙、金字塔在中心拔地而起，它们会被石灰粉刷成白色，就像涂了白漆一样，然后覆盖着美丽的编织旗帜、旗幡、挂毯，有些地方还被涂上了鲜艳的色彩。神庙区四周的街区划分得非常清晰。神庙区也是皇室居住的地方。但在它周围，有非常明显划分的街区，这些街区实际上是由迁徙到那里的氏族或血缘群体繁衍而来的。他们一直保持着对特定血统的意识。他们每个人都有
Or what would we hear or smell? Or what would be the most striking things, do you think? Well, from the centre, if you're looking down or looking at the city from across the water, from the shore of the mainland, you would see two great temples, pyramids rising in the centre, and they would have been painted white with lime, like whitewash, and then covered with beautiful woven banderas, flags, tapestries, and then in some places painted bright colors as well. The neighborhoods were divided very clearly all around this temple precinct. And the temple precinct is also where the royals lived. But around it, there were very clearly marked neighborhoods that were actually descended from clan or kin-based groups that had migrated there. They had remained aware of a certain lineage. And they each had
自己的神庙。他们组织严密，组织化程度极高，因此进贡或税收是以特定方式收集的。在一年中的不同月份，每个群体轮流负责清扫主神庙、清理引水道或湖岸以及建造码头。如果你愿意的话，这是一个高度集中的政府。然后你会发现，每户人家的建造方式是：每栋房子都用泥砖建造，围绕着一个方形庭院，有多栋建筑。其中一些还有二楼，特别是为了可以在上面种植花园，所以当你走在这些秩序井然的街道上时——记住，这一切都是在过去一个世纪内建造的，所以它确实非常有秩序。它并没有像古代欧洲城市那样有机地、
their own temples. And they were organized, very highly organized so that tribute or tax was collected in a certain way. And each group worked on cleaning the main temples or cleaning the aqueducts or the lakeshore and building the docks in different months of the year. Very centralized government, if you will. And then you would have each household would be built, each house built of a do adobe and around a square courtyard, there would be multiple buildings. And then some of them had second floors, especially so that they could grow gardens so that you would walk down these very orderly streets. Remember, this had all been built within the past century. So it really was very orderly. It didn't grow organically and sort of
杂乱无章地生长。他们是在岛上规划好这一切的。所以你走在这些井然有序的街道上，看到两层的泥砖建筑，美丽的鲜花从边缘倾泻而下。他们当时就已经有养鸣禽的习惯了。如今，墨西哥和中美洲以最普通的家庭都饲养鸣禽而闻名。但这种风气在当时就已经开始了。蒙特苏马同样拥有一个动物园和一个鸟舍，里面收集了来自各个领土的不同生物，以便他可以炫耀。是的。而且他还养了一些身体畸形的人。是的。我们不知道程度如何，但确实有证据表明，在这些花园里——我不应该叫它们公共花园，因为我们不知道它们是否必然对游客开放，可以这么说——但在这些皇家花园里，有证据表明有些人违背自己的意愿被关在那里，因为他们有什么引人注目的特征，也许是侏儒症或类似的东西。
in a disorderly way, the way ancient European cities did. They had planned this on the island. So you walked down these orderly streets, seeing two-story adobe buildings with beautiful flowers sort of cascading over the edges. And they were already in the habit of keeping songbirds. Today, Mexico and Central America are famous for the most ordinary of households keep songbirds. But that had already started at that time. Moctezuma likewise had a sort of a zoo and an aviary where different creatures from the territories were collected so that he could show off. Yeah. And he kept people who were kind of physically deformed. Yes. We don't know to what extent, but it is true that in these gardens, I shouldn't call them public gardens because we don't know that they were necessarily open to tourists, so to speak. But in these royal gardens, there is evidence that some people were kept against their will because they had some remarkable feature, perhaps a door or something like this.
但我们对这方面了解不多。这有点像人类动物园之类的东西。对，有点像。不过我不想把这个夸大得太厉害，因为我们对这方面的了解有限。这有点像人类动物园之类的东西。对，有点像。不过我不想把这个夸大得太厉害，因为我们对这方面的了解有限。但这座令人惊呆的城市，我记得曾读到过，它是亨利八世统治下伦敦规模的五倍。难道这不是真的吗？这也是另一个神话吗？事实证明这也是一个神话。现在，这是过去几十年里被一些原本声誉良好的历史学家广为传播的说法，但最近一位考古学家进行了计算——这原本是基于西班牙人拼凑、然后人口统计学家又拼凑出来的纯粹靠猜测的数字。但最近，一位考古学家做了一番数学计算后意识到，你知道的，他们生活的这个岛只有五平方公里。我们当时竟然在推算一个堪比今日曼哈顿的人口密度，这显然是荒谬的。没错。没错。好吧。然而，它确实非常大。堪比今日曼哈顿的人口密度，这显然是荒谬的，对吧？然而，它确实非常大。我们确实认为岛上可能居住着5万人口。如果你把整个中央谷地里那些认为自己是这座城市一部分或与之紧密相连的人都算上，我们可能会接近他们所说的规模。你看，这就是我想请你来的原因，因为我有太多混淆不清的事实想让你来——
But we don't know much about it. It's a kind of human zoo kind of thing. Yeah, a little bit. I don't want to exaggerate that too much, though, because we don't know much about it. It's a kind of human zoo kind of thing. Yeah, a little bit. I don't want to exaggerate that too much, though, because we don't know the extent of it. But this stupefying city that I think I read was five times the size of London under Henry VIII. Is that not true? Is that another of the myths? That turns out to be a myth. Now, that is one that was spread by otherwise reputable historians
我们都有，而且很遗憾，历史学家在这方面也推波助澜了。汤姆，我觉得我们应该聊聊人祭，因为那是——我觉得我们应该在休息之后再谈这个。好吧，没问题。你不觉得吗？我是说——不，不，没问题。因为当然，是的。
in the past few decades, but recently an archaeologist, this was based on numbers that were pure guesswork that the Spaniards had put together and then the demographers put together. But recently, an archaeologist did the math and realized, you know, this island they were living on was five square miles. We were imputing a density of population that rivals that of Manhattan today, which is patently ridiculous. Right. Right. OK. However, it was very big. a population that rivals that of Manhattan today, which is patently ridiculous, right? However, it was very big. We do think there were probably 50,000 people on the island. And if you count all the people in the Central Valley who considered themselves sort of part of this, or connected to that city, we might approach sizes like they have talked about. You see, this is what I wanted you on, because I've got so many kind of garbled facts that I want you to-
我的意思是，我想我们被问到的问题中大约有三分之一都跟人祭有关。而且我知道，强调这个文明的美感和复杂性当然极其重要。但不幸的是，这正是人们想要了解的。我们需要把这两方面都谈到。如果我们不谈人祭，那就是在逃避现实。所以我们去休息一下，快去给自己泡杯巧克力。然后等我们回来，再来聊聊人祭。以及关于娱乐，我们会告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客
We all do, and historians have helped with that, I'm sorry to say. Tom, I think we should get into the human sacrifice, because that is- I think we should do that after the break. Okay, fair enough. Don't you? I mean- No, no, fair enough. Because of course, yes.
和现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。我刚刚喝了一杯轻松的热巧克力。汤姆·霍兰德则去进行了一场人祭，我坚信这是布里克斯顿的正常行为。而卡米拉·汤森大概没有进行过人祭，但她要跟我们聊聊人祭——这显然
I mean, I would say about a third of the questions we've been asked are about the sacrifice. And I know that it's obviously incredibly important to emphasize the beauty, the sophistication of this civilization. But unfortunately, this is what people do want to know about. And we need to talk about both. We'd be in denial if we didn't talk about sacrifice. So let's go and have a quick break. Go and make yourself a cup of chocolate. And then when we come back, we will talk human sacrifice. and on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
是所有英国读者绝对都会跟阿兹特克人联系在一起的一件事。所以卡米拉，我们收到了海量的问题。这里有一个很好的开场问题，来自斯特凡·詹森（Stefan Jensen），他说：抛开人祭不谈——仿佛你能把它抛开不谈一样——阿兹特克人究竟跟我们有多大不同？有趣的是，人祭往往是人们用来证明阿兹特克人与众不同、低人一等或有什么邪恶之类的地方。那么真相究竟是什么呢？
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. I've had a relaxing cup of hot chocolate. Tom Holland has been off to conduct a human sacrifice, as I believe is normal behavior in Brixton. And Camilla Townsend probably hasn't conducted a human sacrifice, but is going to talk to us about human sacrifice, which obviously
我的意思是，他们真的是那种嗜血成性、有这种堕落习俗的角色，还是说他们其实跟我们一样？我强烈认为，在内心深处，这些人跟我们一模一样。现在，确实，人祭是他们文化的一部分，这一点必须承认。近几十年来，我们许多历史学家试图不否认这个事实，但又避免去谈论它，因为我们一直专注于试图将注意力吸引到这些人及其文化的其他方面。但这是必须正视的。
is the one thing that certainly all British readers associate with the Aztecs. So Camilla, we've had tons of questions. So here's a good one to kick off with. It's Stefan Jensen, and he says, human sacrifice aside, as if you can put it aside, how different from us were the Aztecs really? Now, the interesting thing about that is that human sacrifice is often the thing that people have used to show that the Aztecs were different, that they were lesser or that they were some sinister or whatever. So what's the truth?
它是真实存在的。问题在于，我们公众通常只关注阿兹特克文化的这一方面，从而将其扭曲了。在他们的宗教核心、在他们宗教的中心，存在着一个许多人类文化共有的观念，即人类对神明亏欠很多。你应该感谢神明、表达你的感激、向他们献祭。你很难找到一个不包含某种这种元素的宗教。而其中最高的祭品被认为是人类的生命，尤其是美丽、强大、年轻的战士的生命。同样，一个年轻男子、一个年轻人为了自己的人民、为了更大的利益而放弃生命的这种观念，在整个人类
I mean, are they these sort of bloodthirsty characters with this depraved practice, or are they just like us? I would argue strongly that at heart, these people were just like us. Now, it is true. Human sacrifice was a part of their culture, and that must be acknowledged. In recent decades, many of us historians have tried to not deny the fact of that, but avoid talking about it because we've been focused on trying to draw attention to other aspects of these people and of their culture. But it must be addressed.
文明中都非常普遍。而这源于你刚才跟我们讲过的那个神话。是的，或者说那个神话起源于这种信仰，抑或是信仰起源于神话，但它们紧密相连，对吧？所以发生的事情是——我认为，学者、考古学家认为这实际上发生在古代世界的许多地方，只是我们现在对它没有清晰的视线——人们逐渐开始倾向于牺牲战俘、抓来的敌人，而不是牺牲自己的孩子，对吧？我的意思是，这其实挺正常的。
It was real. The problem is that we, in the public, we have in general focused only on that aspect of the Aztec culture and thus have distorted it. At heart, at the center of their religion was a notion common to many human cultures, that is that humans owe the gods a great deal. You ought to thank the gods, show your gratitude, give sacrifice to them. It would be hard-pressed to find a religion that didn't have some element of that. And the greatest sacrifice was considered to be human life, especially the life of a beautiful, strong, young warrior. Again, the idea of a young man, a young person giving up his life for his people, for the greater good, this is very common across human
好吧，我们保留了必须给神明送上一份厚礼的信念，但这不一定非得是我亲爱的孩子，对吧？我的意思是，这其实挺正常的。好吧，我们保留了必须给神明送上一份厚礼的信念，但不一定非得是我可怜的孩子，对吧？可以是那些攻击我们却被我们击败的人。而且这种情况一直在持续——人们认为这发生在所有古代或绝大多数古代文明中。全球各地都有这方面的蛛丝马迹。我们知道这种情况在新世界各地都在继续。也就是说，几乎所有的美洲原住民都会在仪式上偶尔献祭一个战俘。如果在战争中被俘，年轻的妇女和儿童几乎总是被收养，但年轻的战士或酋长则面临尖刀或火刑。而且这一切都是以极大的荣誉进行的。
civilization. And which originates from that myth that you were telling us about. Yes, or that myth originates from the belief or the belief from the myth, but they're tightly tied together, right? So what happened, and I think this, well, scholars, archaeologists believe this happened actually in many parts of the world in ancient times. It's just that we don't have a clear view of it now, was that people gradually began to prefer to sacrifice a prisoner of war, someone taken, you know, an enemy that had been taken instead of one of their own children, right? I mean, that is rather normal.
如果一个人死时没有发出尖叫，他就会获得最高的荣誉。所以这并不旨在贬低敌人。这是战争的一部分，与尊崇神明有关。好吧，确实，在完整语境下对人类来说可以说是悲剧般正常的这种习俗，在阿兹特克人统治下呈现出了新的角度。正如我所提到的，他们是最后一批到达谷地的移民，他们为自己的地位而战。到了那个世纪末，他们变得如此强大，以至于他们确实需要努力维持对一个辽阔帝国的统治。这是一个没有机枪的世界，对吧？他们的武器与邻居
Okay, we maintain the belief that we must give the gods a great gift, but it doesn't have to be my Maryb children, right? I mean, that is rather normal. Okay, we maintain the belief that we must give the gods a great gift, but it doesn't have to be my Marybeth, right? It'll be these people who attacked us and we defeated. And that went on, again, it's thought that this happened in all ancient or most ancient civilizations. There are hints about that all across the globe. We know that it went on across the New World. That is, that almost all Native Americans ritually sacrificed an occasional prisoner of war. Young women and children were almost always adopted if they were taken in war, but young warriors or chiefs faced the knife or faced the burning. And it was done with all great honor.
或敌人并没有本质上的区别。所以他们真的需要深挖下去，找到恐吓人们的方法。于是他们开始以前所未有、连他们自己和他们的人民过去从未做过的规模来进行人祭。我不知道世界上其他地方的情况。事实上，在我读过的一份编年史中，他们实际上谈到了这一点：有时他们喜欢去——在他们的统治临近结束时，当这种权力达到顶峰，
If a guy died without screaming, he was given the highest honor. So it wasn't intended necessarily to denigrate the enemy. It was part of war and it had to do with honoring the gods. Well, it is true that that custom that sort of in full context is tragically normal for human beings, took on a new angle under the Aztecs. They were the last migrants to arrive in the valley, as I've mentioned, and they fought for their position. And towards the end of that century, they had become so powerful that they really needed to try to maintain power over a far-flung empire. And this was a world without machine guns, right? They didn't have weaponry that was profoundly different from their neighbors
有人可能会说他们的偏执也达到顶峰时，他们会去他们试图征服的地区抓走年轻人，把他们带到城里，让他们观看这种数十人被杀、而不仅仅是一人被杀的可怖祭祀。然后把他们送回家，让他们离开。他们明确表示，这样做的目的是让他们回家告诉自己的人民：最好趁我们还能加入的时候赶紧加入这个帝国，不要跟他们对抗，因为我们可不想让我们的年轻人不得不经历那样的人祭。所以这是有目的的。在我看来，
or their enemies. So they really needed to sort of dig in and find ways to terrorize people. And they began to commit human sacrifice on a scale that had never been done before by them and their people. I don't know about other regions in the world. And in fact, in one of the annals that I have read, they actually talk about this, that they sometimes liked to go, at the very end of their reign, when this power was peaking
这并不是因为所有阿兹特克人都真诚地相信，如果他们在一年中不献祭数千人，神明就会发怒，太阳就会消失——那种刻板印象。但他们的宗教中确实有这样一层内核。然而现实却是政治性的，这太常见了。我的意思是，我们可以看看我挚爱的国家的政府，对吧？在20世纪70年代和80年代，我的政府为了在拉丁美洲维持权力，曾以我们的名义做出过多么可怕的事情。所以我觉得，说他们在许多方面与我们现在非常相似，并不过分夸张。我脑海里有很多关于阿兹特克人及其神明的固有印象。我相当确凿地只想对它们进行压力测试。
and their paranoia, one could argue, was peaking, they would go and take young people from the area they were trying to conquer, bring them to the city, have them watch these horrible sacrifices in which dozens of people were killed, not just one. And then send them home, let them go. And they explicitly said this was with the idea of having them go home and tell their people, we better join this empire while we can and not fight them because we don't want our young people to have to be sacrificed like that. So it was purposeful. It does not seem to me that
可以说，他们的偏执狂达到了顶峰，他们会去他们试图征服的地区抓走年轻人，把他们带到城里，让他们观看这些可怕的献祭，其中数十人被杀，而不止一人。然后把他们送回家，让他们离开。他们明确表示，这样做的目的是让他们回家告诉自己的人民，我们最好趁早加入这个帝国，不要与他们战斗，因为我们不想让我们年轻的人民被这样献祭。所以这是有目的的。在我看来，这似乎
this happened because all the Aztecs truly believed that if they didn't sacrifice thousands of people in the course of a year, the gods would be angry and the sun would disappear, that sort of stereotype. But there's a kernel of that in their religion. But then the reality was political, as it so often is. I mean, we can look at the government of my own beloved country, right? Horrible things were done in the 1970s and 80s by my government in our name to maintain power in Latin America. So I think it isn't much of a stretch to say that in many ways, they are or were very much like we are now. I've got a whole load of things that I thought that I knew about the Aztecs and their gods. And I'm fairly sure that I just want to basically stress test them.
发生并不是因为阿兹特克人真的相信，如果他们一年内不牺牲成千上万的人，众神就会生气，太阳就会消失，这种刻板印象。但他们的宗教中确实有这方面的核心内涵。然而现实往往是政治性的，就像通常情况一样。我的意思是，我们可以看看我挚爱的国家的政府，对吧？在20世纪70年代和80年代，我的政府以我们的名义做出了可怕的事情，以维持在拉丁美洲的权力。所以我认为，说他们在很多方面非常像现在的我们，并不是一件很夸张的事。我有一大堆自以为很了解的关于阿兹特克人及其神灵的事情。而且我相当确定，我基本上只想对它们进行压力测试。
So tell me if these are right or wrong. Did the Aztecs think that warriors who were sacrificed and women who died in childbirth turned into hummingbirds? Yes and no. So like ancient Greece, like the classical world, there was some division, some debate about what happened after you died. It wasn't universally agreed upon. Think about some people in the ancient world believed in the Orpheus cult and others did not. So likewise, in ancient Mexico, different areas had somewhat different views of this. But in general, life was the golden period and in death, you were a shade, a shadow who would soon be forgotten and then no longer exist. Except if you died as a warrior or as a sacrifice victim in war or a woman who died in childbirth.
那么告诉我，这些对不对。阿兹特克人是否认为，作为祭品的战士和死于难产的妇女会变成蜂鸟？答案是也不是。就像古希腊或古典世界一样，关于人死后会发生什么，当时存在一些分歧和争论，并不是所有人都达成了共识。就像古希腊罗马世界里，有些人信仰俄耳甫斯教派，而另一些人则不信。同样，在古代墨西哥，不同地区对死后世界的看法也有所不同。但总体而言，活着才是黄金时期，而在死后，你只是一缕幽魂、一个影子，很快就会被遗忘，然后彻底不复存在。除非你是作为战士、战争中的祭品，或是死于难产的妇女而死。
Then you fed the gods and especially the sun. You lived for, it's debatable, probably four more years in a golden world where you were feeding the sun. And symbolically, metaphorically, you did this as a bird or a butterfly. That's beautiful. But it's not, we don't think that they thought, oh, look at that hummingbird. It's probably Uncle Joe, right? I mean, it wasn't a sort of literal thing like that,
那么，你就是在供养神明，尤其是太阳。你大概还会活上——这还有争议——大约四年，生活在一个供养太阳的黄金世界里。而且在象征和隐喻的层面，你是以鸟类或蝴蝶的形式做到这一点的。这很美妙。但这并不意味着他们会想：“哦，看那只蜂鸟，那可能是乔叔叔吧？”我的意思是，这并不是那种字面意义上的事情，
but a more beautiful and metaphorical. But there's a kind of poetry there that's authentic. Oh, absolutely. Absolutely. Yes, yes, yes yes yes okay so from hummingbirds to something slightly bloodier is it true that aztec priests were in the habit of stabbing their penises with sharp thorns yes the listeners want to know this i mean you you told me you were gonna i mean tom has been saying he's going to ask this. So it's clearly playing on his mind. God knows, Camilla, what's going on in their subconscious.
而是一种更优美、更具隐喻性的说法。但其中包含着一种真实的诗意。哦，绝对是。绝对是的。对，对，对，对，好吧。那么，从蜂鸟转到一个稍微有点血腥的话题：阿兹特克祭司真的有拿尖刺扎自己阴茎的习惯吗？是的，听众朋友们很想知道这个。我的意思是，你之前说过你打算——汤姆一直在说他要问这个。所以这显然一直在他脑子里盘旋。谁知道呢，卡米拉，他们的潜意识里到底在想些什么。
I think I read that when I was about eight and it's haunted me ever since. It was. It's very true. It's in the histories. It's in the poems. And in fact, that was probably. Well, it was more common than human sacrifice. That is one thing that all young men did growing up in order to become tough was take part in ritual ceremonies in which you bled yourself, you bled your penis a little bit. The idea was not to do lasting damage, but just to show
我想我大概八岁的时候读到过这个，从此它就一直萦绕在我的脑海里。确实如此。史料里有记载，诗歌里也有。事实上，这可能……嗯，这比活人献祭还要普遍。这是所有年轻人在成长过程中为了变得坚强而必须做的一件事，那就是参加自残的仪式，让你自己流血，让你的阴茎流一点血。这样做的目的不是造成永久性的伤害，而只是为了展示
how tough you were. And to thank the gods. Just to show how tough you are, basically. It's a resilience test. Yes. And thank the gods. I mean, again, your blood is feeding the earth and hence the divinity but i would absolutely argue that you're showing how strong you are how impressive you are i don't think it's something we should bring in on this show tom teenage pics all through the night um okay the most terrifying god is he the most terrifying god so there was a fabulous exhibition um at the royal academy here in london about 20 years ago and there was a statue of a god that looked to be wearing bubble wrap and you'll know immediately i'm talking about and i thought oh how it looks like a children's
你有多坚强。并且以此感谢神明。基本上就是为了展示你有多坚强。这是一场耐力测试。是的。顺便感谢神明。我的意思是，话说回来，你的血液滋养了大地，从而滋养了神灵；但我绝对要说，这也是在展示你有多强大，多令人印象深刻。我觉得我们不应该在这个节目里提到这个，汤姆，整晚都在看青少年色情图片。嗯，好吧，最可怕的神是谁？他是最可怕的神吗？大约20年前，伦敦皇家艺术学院举办过一场极棒的展览，里面有一尊神的雕塑，看起来就像穿了一身气泡膜，你马上就会知道我在说哪一个。当时我想：“哦，这看起来多像一个儿童
character and then i read the sign and said this is a flayed skin turned inside out and this is the fat of the inside the skin that has formed little bubbles. And this god is Chipitotec, our lord, the flayed one. And the priests went around wearing flayed skins. Is that true? Yes. And in fact, at first, early on in their culture, there would have been some element of this. That is, a priest would have done something like that. The idea of taking on the persona of the sacrifice victim, which was a very holy and revered. I mean, they were part of the ones pushing this, a bit like military generals pushing a particular war.
角色啊。”然后我读了旁边的说明，上面写着：“这是一张剥下来的皮，被翻转了过来，皮肤内部的脂肪形成了小小的气泡。”这位神就是希佩托特克（Xipe Totec），我们的主，剥皮者。而且祭司们会穿着剥下来的皮到处走。这是真的吗？是的。事实上，在他们文化的早期，这其中确实包含某些成分。也就是说，祭司会做类似的事情。这种做法是为了扮演祭品的角色，这在当时是一件非常神圣且备受尊崇的事。我的意思是，他们是推动这件事的力量之一，有点像军事将领在极力促成某场特定的战争。
It was good for their professional identity for there to be more of this human sacrifice. And clearly some of them, well, they were not the kind of guy you'd want to bring home for dinner. They must have stunk. No, I was about to say, not if they're wearing someone else's skin. Now, again, keep in mind that at the same time as this was going on, Aztec poets, some of them were singing about the tragic nature of war and the tragedy of life ending and the great beauty of life. So all Aztecs were not the same. I mean, that sounds silly, but my point is some of these priests were real dastardly dudes, but all Aztecs
为了他们自身的职业利益，他们也希望有更多的活人献祭。而且很显然，他们中的一些人——嗯，绝对不是那种你想请回家吃晚饭的人。他们身上肯定有一股臭味。不，我正要说，如果他们穿着别人的皮的话。现在，再次提醒大家，在这一切发生的同时，阿兹特克诗人们也在歌唱战争的悲剧本质、生命消逝的悲剧以及生命无与伦比的美丽。所以，并不是所有的阿兹特克人都一个样。听起来这像是一句废话，但我的意思是，虽然有些祭司确实是十恶不赦的恶棍，但并不是所有的阿兹特克人
weren't like that. Dominic, can I just read Denver Brito's question? Because he says, do we know of sentiment against sacrifice among the Aztecs? That's exactly what I was going to ask. Oh, sorry, Dominic. Is there a debate? Do we have evidence, textual
都那样。多米尼克，我能读一下丹佛·布里托（Denver Brito）的问题吗？因为他说：“我们知道阿兹特克人当中是否存在反对献祭的情绪吗？”这正是我想要问的。哦，对不起，多米尼克。这其中有争议吗？我们是否有证据，文字
evidence of an actual debate within us? I guess I wouldn't go so far as to say that there was any sort of formalised debate. But just that within these songs that are a bit different from the histories, the songs are the poems, but they were sung aloud. There's clearly there are multiple different and competing threads. Some of them celebrate war, but actually very few. That's rather rare in the songs. A more dominant thread would be the tragic nature of violence. Because life was heaven. This life on earth was the best that there was. They really felt strongly, even for the warriors who get to live as hummingbirds for four years. Life was what they continuously spoke with reverence and joy about. Life was what you were supposed to be. Be the best human that you can because this is it, folks. And there's no question that part of that sort of dialogue or discourse was just a love of life, a joy in life.
证据来证明我们内部确实存在这种争论？我想我不会走得那么远，去说当时存在任何形式的正式辩论。但只是在这些不同于历史记载的歌曲中——这些歌曲其实就是诗歌，但它们是被大声唱出来的——很明显，其中存在着多种不同且相互竞争的线索。有些歌曲赞美战争，但实际上非常少。在这些歌曲中这相当罕见。更为主流的倾向反而是暴力所具有的悲剧本质。因为生活就是天堂。人世间的这短暂一生是至高无上的。他们对此有着极其强烈的情感，甚至对于那些得以化作蜂鸟生活四年的战士来说也是如此。生命是他们不断以敬畏和喜悦之情谈论的话题。生活就是你应当去经历的全部。尽你所能去成为一个最优秀的人，因为这就是全部了，各位。毫无疑问，这种对话或讨论的一部分，正是对生活的热爱，对生命的喜悦。
All sorts of metaphors were used comparing to flowers, etc. So the idea that it was good to have to kill the enemy, I don't think I've ever come across that. You do find it's good that we won. But in terms of all the death and human sacrifice, the songs talk about it as a sad thing. I would argue that most likely the priests who were by now living on their own in these temple pyramids, they probably were not singing those songs. They had, I think, a different view. And I say that based on their actions. We don't have their words. Okay, so Camilla, one last question about gods.
他们使用了各种各样的隐喻，将其与花朵等事物进行比较。所以，认为杀害敌人是件好事这种观点，我想我从来没遇到过。你或许会发现人们觉得“我们赢了真好”。但就所有的死亡和活人献祭而言，歌曲中谈到这些时，都将其视为一件悲伤的事情。我认为极有可能是这样的：那些当时已经独自住在神庙金字塔里的祭司们，大概不会唱这些歌。我认为他们有着不同的视角。我之所以这么说，是基于他们的实际行动。我们并没有留下他们的话语。好吧，卡米拉，关于神明的最后一个问题。
And in some ways, I mean, this is the detail that has haunted me most of all. The god Tlaloc, who is the god of the rain. And is it true that children were particularly sacrificed to him and that if they cried, then the sacrifice was more efficacious? It is true. That is, the myth is that Aztecs ran around killing a lot of women and children. They did not. It was almost always prisoners of war, male prisoners of war, young warriors.
从某种程度上说——我的意思是，这是最让我挥之不去的细节。雨神特拉洛克（Tlaloc）。传说中，人们尤其会将儿童献祭给他，而且如果这些儿童哭了，献祭就会更有效，这是真的吗？这是真的。也就是说，那种认为阿兹特克人到处滥杀妇女儿童的说法是不真实的。几乎所有的牺牲品都是战俘，即男性战俘和年轻战士。
However, there were certain ceremonies. I mean, there was festival days, religious days went throughout the calendar. And there were certain ones where women died, and there was this one, the ceremony dedicated to Tlaloc, where a handful of children were sacrificed. And there is debate about who these children were. Some scholars have argued that they were their own children. However, there's no textual evidence of that. And in fact, archaeologists have found that these were always malnourished children. So I would argue strongly that these were undoubtedly also prisoners of war from impoverished areas. It was of ceremonial importance in many ceremonies, many festivals, and even on political occasions. If a chief cried as he uttered a certain statement, that meant he would not break his word.
然而，确实存在某些特定的仪式。我的意思是，日历上排满了各种节日和宗教节日。在某些特定的日子里，会有妇女死去；而在专属特拉洛克的这个仪式中，会有少数儿童被献祭。关于这些儿童的身份，目前仍存在争议。一些学者曾争辩说，他们是阿兹特克人自己的孩子。然而，并没有文字证据支持这一说法。事实上，考古学家发现，这些被献祭的儿童无一例外都营养不良。因此我坚决认为，毫无疑问，这些同样是来自贫困地区的战俘。这在许多仪式、许多节日甚至政治场合中都具有重要的礼仪意义。如果一个首领在发表某项声明时哭了，那就意味着他绝不会食言。
So public tears were important. And yes, when the children cried, it was considered a good sign. There is some evidence that sometimes the children were drugged so that they didn't suffer. But given that there was some hope that the children would cry, I suspect not enough so that they could, you know, to death was a known phenomenon to everyone. So there's no question that when these children, women or warriors were taken in war, they knew what might be their fate. So on that question of how much the Aztecs were familiar with the world beyond them, I mean, obviously, they had no idea that Europe existed. But a question from Harold Wilson, how much do the Aztecs know about the Inca and the wider world in general? So were there links with the Inca Empire?
因此，公开流泪是一件很重要的事。是的，当孩子们哭泣时，这被认为是一个好兆头。有一些证据表明，有时人们会给孩子们喂食迷药，好让他们少受些痛苦。但考虑到当时人们对孩子们哭泣抱有某种期待，我猜药量并不会大到让他们——你知道的，致死是每个人都知道的现象。因此毫无疑问，当这些儿童、妇女或战士在战争中被俘时，他们很清楚自己可能会面临什么命运。关于阿兹特克人对他们世界之外的世界了解多少这个问题，显然，他们根本不知道欧洲的存在。但有一个来自哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）的问题：阿兹特克人对印加人以及更广泛的世界了解多少？那么，他们和印加帝国之间有什么联系吗？
This was a world that had only been sedentary, that had only been farming for a couple of millennia. So they were still sort of roughly where the ancient Sumerians or the Mesopotamians were in terms of their technological development. So theyians or the Mesopotamians were in terms of their technological development. So they had canoes, for example, but they hadn't turned those canoes into sailing vessels. They had some rather simple maps, but they didn't have compasses, etc. So no, they did not have direct knowledge of vast territories. Their own empire extended as far as today's El Salvador, and it also went up the coast sort of in the direction of San Diego, although never got that far. And because they went far in their military exploits, through long distance trade networks, they had heard of other kingdoms. So they were aware that there were other kingdoms out there far, far away, but they couldn't have told you, yes, and the leading ones' names are the Incas,
这是一个直到最近两千年才进入定居和农业社会的文明。因此，就他们的技术发展水平而言，他们大致还处于古代苏美尔人或美索不达米亚人的阶段。所以，他们拥有独木舟之类的东西，但他们没有把这些独木舟改造成帆船。他们有一些相当简陋的地图，但没有指南针等工具。所以，不，他们对广阔的领土并没有直接的认识。他们自己的帝国向南一直延伸到今天的萨尔瓦多，沿着海岸线也曾向圣迭戈的方向延伸过，尽管从未到达过那么远。而且由于他们在军事远征中走得很远，通过长途贸易网络，他们听说过其他王国。所以他们知道在遥远的地方还有其他王国，但他们无法告诉你：“对不起，最强大的那些王国名字叫印加，
and they did this and that. Like the Romans and the Chinese, perhaps. Exactly. I think that's a very good comparison. Right. So Camilla, you raise technology, and I think this is a massively fascinating topic. It's one that tons of our listeners have asked about. And in your book, I mean, I'm paraphrasing your book, so maybe you should be doing it, but you have this incredibly interesting argument about, it's basically a sort of clash of two time zones. The Spanish from the 16th century and the Aztecs who are basically thousands of years behind, as it works. They haven't been sedentary for as long. So my question, I guess, is a very, very basic one. Why? Why have people in the Americas not been sedentary farmers at the same time as the Sumerians or the Babylonians or whatever? Right. It's an excellent question. And
他们做过这事和那事。”就像罗马人和中国人一样，也许吧。完全正确。我认为这是一个非常恰当的类比。好的。卡米拉，你提到了技术，我认为这是一个极其迷人的话题。这也是我们的无数听众一直追问的问题。而在你的书里——我的意思是，我是在用我自己的话复述你的书，所以也许这本该由你来做——你提出了一个极其有趣的论点，这基本上可以看作是两个时区的冲突。16th世纪的西班牙人，与基本上落后了数千年的阿兹特克人狭路相逢。他们定居的时间没有那么久。所以我的问题其实非常非常基础：为什么？为什么美洲的人民没有和苏美尔人、巴比伦人或其他人同时成为定居的农民呢？没错。这是一个极好的问题，
in fact, it's one that we haven't had an answer to until quite recently, because until the mid 90s, radiocarbon dating techniques, they weren't good enough. They weren't fine-tuned enough to tell us when which plant or which crop got to which point. We just knew, for example, in the old world that wheat seemed to be everywhere for the past few thousand years. But in human history, that doesn't really tell us much. So starting in the 90s, scholars were able to plot where wheat and peas got when, when people exactly began to farm corn and beans in the New World, etc. Well, it turns out, in retrospect, this makes perfect sense.
事实上，直到最近我们才找到答案。因为在90年代中期之前，放射性碳测年技术还不够成熟。它们的精确度还不足以告诉我们哪种植物或哪种农作 物在什么时候发展到了什么阶段。我们只知道，例如在旧世界，过去几千年来小麦似乎随处可见。但在人类历史上，这并不能说明太多问题。因此，从90年代开始，学者们能够绘制出小麦和小扁豆出现的时间，以及人们究竟是从什么时候开始在新世界种植玉米和豆类的，等等。好吧，事后看来，这完全合乎情理。
It turns out people became full-time farmers where there was a constellation of protein-rich crops that were suitable for that. You don't give up hunting unless you have a good protein-rich substitute. And in the Fertile Crescent that you are also familiar with, you had legumes, peas, and wheat, and the wild forms were very protein-rich. That constellation of crops rapidly spread east and west, and Europe and China added other crops and became farmers too. Well, in the New World, it took a lot longer. The ancient ancestor of corn, teosinte, was much tinier and less protein rich. So, people everywhere were sort of flirting with farming, planting their favorite plants and then coming back next year to see if more of the cranberries or the wild corn had grown. But meanwhile, they were relying more on hunting. So they flirted with farming and over several millennia, they did turn the teeny tiny teosinte
事实证明，只有在存在一组富含蛋白质且适宜种植的农作物的地方，人们才会成为专职农民。除非你有富含蛋白质的优质替代品，否则你绝不会放弃狩猎。在你们也十分熟悉的“新月沃地”，那里有豆类、小扁豆和小麦，它们的野生品种都富含蛋白质。这一组农作物迅速向东西方传播，欧洲和中国也加入了种植其他作物的行列，并同样成为了农民。而在新世界，这个过程花了更长的时间。玉米的古代祖先——大刍草，个头要小得多，蛋白质含量也低得多。因此，各地的人们都在断断续续地尝试农业，种植他们最喜欢的植物，然后在第二年回来看看是否有更多的蔓越莓或野生玉米长出来。但与此同时，他们仍然更加依赖狩猎。所以他们对农业只是浅尝辄止，经过了几千年，他们才把那小小的大刍草
into an ear of corn. And then at some point, they realized, and this took more time, that if you ate corn on the same day as you ate beans, you had enough protein to live. You didn't have to hunt down a deer. It's like eating a hamburger if you have corn and beans together, but not separately. Wheat and peas on their own are good enough. So it took about 5,000 more years in the new world than in the old. Not for people to start flirting with farming, as I call it, but for people to really settle down and become full-time farmers. And that didn't make them stupid. Not at all. I mean, the Aztecs I study, the writings that I read, these are the works of some rather brilliant men, especially some of the poems. And I would argue that women were just as smart, but that's another question. But indeed, it's just that they had not been sedentary for nearly as long. So they had not had the same number of millennia to invent all the things that come with sedentary life. You can't have a blacksmith shop or develop a writing system and a tribute system if you're on the move every day. You can only move with
培育成了玉米棒。然后，在某个时刻，他们意识到——这花了更多的时间——如果你在吃玉米的同一天也吃豆类，你摄入的蛋白质就足够维持生命了。你不需要非得去猎杀一头鹿。这就好比把玉米和豆类混在一起吃，就相当于吃了一个汉堡，但如果分开吃就不行。而小麦和小扁豆本身就足够好了。因此，在新世界，这比在旧世界多花了大约5000年的时间。这倒不是说人们开始像我所说的那样尝试农业花了这么久，而是说人们真正定居下来、成为专职农民花了这么久。但这并不意味着他们变笨了。一点也不。我的意思是，我所研究的阿兹特克人，我所阅读的那些著作，都是一些相当杰出的人的作品，尤其是其中的一些诗歌。而且我认为女性同样聪明，但这又是另一个问题了。总之，事实只是他们定居的时间远没有那么长。所以他们没有足够多的数千年时间来发明伴随定居生活而产生的所有事物。如果你每天都在迁徙，你就不可能开办铁匠铺，也不可能发展出一套文字系统和朝贡体系。你随身能带的只有
what you have on your back, keep on going, hunt the next deer or the next rabbit. So it makes sense. Do you need all that for wheels? Because obviously that's one thing that people always ask about, where are the wheels? There's a great example. It's not just metallurgy and ships but the wheel and in fact um the incas for instance um also late comers to farming like like the mesoamericans um they had begun to develop a wheel they had it in certain toys and ritual objects obviously it would not have taken much longer i would guess another generation or two for them to start wheeling carts around okay we're not going to go into the detail of the Spanish conquest because I think we should save that for another episode. I mean, it's such an astonishing story. But on that topic,
背上的那些东西，只能不断前行，去猎取下一头鹿或下一只兔子。所以这一切都是合乎情理的。那你们需要这些东西来发明轮子吗？因为显然这也是人们总是追问的一个问题：轮子在哪里？这是一个极好的例子。不仅是冶金术和船只，还有轮子。事实上，比如说印加人——
there is a question here from Costas Cofaris. If the Aztecs had had another couple of centuries to advance technologically and administratively, might they have been able to hold the Spaniards off? And a question from Victoria Adams, could there have been a more peaceful, less destructive outcome for the Aztecs? Or did disease mean that first contact with the Spaniards was going to end very badly for them? So I guess the question is, was there any way in which once the Spanish had reached Mexico, that the Aztec empire could have survived? I don't think so. No matter how brilliant you are, I guess that word means something different to me than it does to you, but no matter how
这里有一个来自科斯塔斯·科法里斯（Costas Cofaris）的问题。如果阿兹特克人在技术和行政上再多获得几个世纪的发展时间，他们是否能够抵挡住西班牙人的进攻？还有一个来自维多利亚·亚当斯（Victoria Adams）的问题：对于阿兹特克人来说，有没有可能出现一种更和平、破坏性更小的结局？还是说，瘟疫意味着与西班牙人的初次接触注定会给他们带来极其糟糕的结局？所以我的猜测是，一旦西班牙人抵达墨西哥，阿兹特克帝国是否有任何可能幸存下来？我不这么认为。无论你多么聪明——我想这个词对我的意义和对你的意义可能有些不同——但无论你多么
intelligent and savvy you are, you can't make up on your own for a 5,000-year technological differential. I do think that had things gone a bit differently in certain specific regards, they could have held the Spaniards off for a bit longer. You might think of Japan holding the West off for a bit longer, so to speak. This can happen with the right rulership and with some bad luck on the side of the Europeans. But that's a lot different from arguing that the Aztec as a state, as a nation could have survived indefinitely. I don't see that happening. As for having accomplished the whole shift, the whole conquest, the whole set of events more peacefully, I suppose it might have been possible. One of the Indigenous women who was pressed into translating for Cortes Malinche or Doña Marina, she seems to have worked quite hard to save Indigenous lives by telling people, work with these guys, be their partner rather than their enemy, and you can come out ahead.
聪明机智，你都无法仅凭一己之力弥补长达5000年的技术代差。我的确认为，如果在某些特定方面事情稍微有些不同，他们本可以把西班牙人阻挡更长的时间。你或许可以想象一下日本将西方人阻挡更久的那种情况，可以说是那么回事。只要有正确的统治权，再加上欧洲人的一些霉运，这是完全可能发生的。但这与宣称阿兹特克作为一个国家、作为一个民族能够无限期存续下去，完全是两码事。我看不出这种可能性。至于说以更和平的方式完成整个政权的更迭、整个征服过程、整套历史事件，我想这也许是可能的。其中一位被迫充当科尔特斯翻译的土著女性——玛林切（Malinche）或多娜·玛丽娜（Doña Marina）——她似乎为了拯救土著人的生命付出了相当大的努力，她对人们说：“与这些人合作，做他们的伙伴而不是敌人，你们就能获得更好的结果。”
And some of the Indigenous villages who took that path did come out ahead of others. So perhaps the whole thing could have been done with less bloodshed. But as your listener has alluded to, microbes were part of the European arsenal. Because of long distance trade and farming, there were far more diseases endemic in Europe and Asia than there were in the New World, where people had not been living with their animals for millennia. So I think that given the brutal realities of the epidemics, people were going to suffer even if peace talks had prevented some of the wars. But Camilla, can I ask a question? Some historians, as far as I understand it, argue that the real,
而那些采取了这条道路的土著村庄，确实比其他村庄得到了更好的结局。所以也许整场变故本可以伴随着更少的流血发生。但正如你的听众所暗示的那样，微生物也是欧洲人武器库的一部分。由于长途贸易和农业的发展，欧洲和亚洲的风土病远比新世界要多，而在新世界，人们并没有和动物朝夕相处数千年。因此我认为，鉴于流行病带来的残酷现实，即使和平谈判阻止了部分战争，人们依然会遭受苦难。不过，卡米拉，我可以问一个问题吗？据我所知，一些历史学家认为，真正带来——
I mean, the pandemics aside, which obviously the Spanish themselves couldn't really do much about, that the really sort of tough times for the indigenous people actually came much later than we think. So in other words, after independence from Spain in the 19th century, that was when things got really rough for the kind of native people of Mexico, rather than as we commonly imagine, you know, in the aftermath of the conquest. Is that right? Or am I misremembering or exaggerating? No, you're remembering quite rightly. And in some ways, I would argue that is quite right. There's no question that the generation or two after conquest was very difficult for the
我的意思是，撇开西班牙人自己也无能为力的那些大流行病不谈，对土著人民来说，真正艰难的日子其实比我们想象的要晚得多。换句话说，在19世纪摆脱西班牙独立之后，那才是墨西哥本土人民的日子真正变得艰难的时候，而不是像我们通常想象的那样，发生在征服之后的余波中。是这样吗？还是我的记忆有误或有所夸大？不，你的记忆完全正确。从某种程度上说，我认为这相当准确。毫无疑问，征服后的一两代人对
indigenous people. The population dropped because of diseases, they had to accustom themselves to a whole new set of rulers who had no real respect for them. The Aztecs did have respect for the people that they were conquering. So there's no question that we watch sort of precipitous drop or level in knowledge of their ancient cultures, precipitous drop in population. They suffered in the 16th century. It is true, however, that in order to make their empire go round, the Spaniards very cleverly developed a system whereby they call it the dos republicas, the two republics. They would rule the Spanish people of Spanish descent in one way and the people of indigenous descent in another way.
土著人民来说非常艰难。由于疾病，人口锐减，他们必须适应全新的一套统治者，而这些统治者对他们没有任何真正的尊重。相比之下，阿兹特克人对他们所征服的人民还是有所尊重的。因此毫无疑问，我们目睹了他们对自身古代文化的认知急剧下降，人口也急剧减少。他们在16th世纪确实饱受折磨。不过，事实确实是，为了让他们的帝国顺畅运转，西班牙人非常聪明地发展出了一套被称为“两共和国”（dos repúblicas）的制度。他们用一种方式统治西班牙血统的人民，用另一种方式统治土著血统的人民。
And as long as the indigenous people complied on a certain level, they could even rule themselves, that they could even have indigenous chiefs continue to rule them. And so there was a sort of sense of parallel worlds. There were whole sections of the university devoted to having scholars learn indigenous languages. Why? So that people, native people could come to court and speak in their own language, for instance. So one could argue that a sort of stasis was reached of mutual accommodation over the colonial era that broke completely when they broke from Spain. That in the independence era, all bets were off. The new Republican government said all citizens are equal.
只要土著人民在某种程度上服从管束，他们甚至可以实行自治，甚至可以由土著首领继续统治他们。因此，当时存在一种平行世界的奇妙感觉。大学里甚至有整个系别专门让学者们学习土著语言。为什么？这样一来，当地人就可以来到法庭上用他们自己的语言发言。所以人们可以说，在殖民时期，双方达成了一种相互妥协的停滞状态，而这种状态在他们与西班牙决裂时彻底打破了。在独立时期，一切都成了未知数。新的共和政体政府宣布所有公民一律平等。
There will be no special allowances made for Indians, no indigenous languages in court. You each have the right to have your own land, for example. So show us your title. Well, of course, the indigenous people just had tradition. They didn't have their title. So yes, the average breadbasket, so to speak, of the typical native descended family in Mexico, it really declined dramatically over the 1800s. And hence, they ended up being part of the great Mexican revolution of the 19-teens. Yeah, Zapata and stuff.
不会再为印第安人提供任何特殊津贴，法庭上也不再使用土著语言。例如，每个人都有权拥有自己的土地。好吧，那请出示您的房契。当然，土著人民只有传统，他们并没有房契。所以，是的，在19世纪期间，墨西哥典型土著后裔家庭的所谓“粮仓”（经济来源）确实急剧萎缩。因此，他们最终成为了2010年代那场伟大的墨西哥革命的一部分。是的，就像萨帕塔（Zapata）他们那样。
Right, with Zapata and stuff. Right, absolutely. With Zapata and Pancho Villa, exactly. So you're not wrong. But I wouldn't want to say that the conquest of the 16th century was a cakewalk. That had its own challenges, right? And we talked about this right at the beginning with the myths that are commonly believed. And the assumption is that the Aztecs thought that the world was ending. And you very powerfully and movingly
对，就像萨帕塔和他的同伴们那样。没错，绝对是的。就像萨帕塔和庞乔·维拉（Pancho Villa）一样，完全正确。所以你并没有记错。但我绝不会说16th世纪的征服是一场轻松的散步。那有着它自身巨大的挑战，对吧？我们在节目一开始就谈到了人们普遍相信的那些神话。人们的假设是，阿兹特克人当时以为世界就要毁灭了。而你用极其有力且动人的方式
demonstrate that that was not the case because they didn't have time for that kind of myth-making. They were trying to stay alive. Right. They were trying to stay alive. First, they were trying to win the war against the Spaniards. And then when that became impossible, they were trying to stay alive. Then they were trying to keep their culture alive, writing down all these histories. And thank goodness they did. I have come across, in all the reading I've done over these two decades now, no evidence that they thought the world was going to end. There was one period in the 1580s when the disease had taken such a toll, generation after generation, that they began to worry a bit. Will our population someday disappear? That was as close as they ever came to thinking that the world would end.
证明了事实并非如此，因为他们根本没有时间去进行那种神话般的臆想。他们当时正忙着活下去。没错。他们当时正忙着活下去。起初，他们试图赢得与西班牙人的战争；而当这变得不可能时，他们试图活下去。接着，他们试图让自己的文化活下来，写下了所有这些历史。谢天谢地，他们确实这么做了。在我这二十年来所阅读的所有资料中，我从未发现任何证据表明他们认为世界将会毁灭。在1580年代的某一个时期，由于疾病一代又一代地夺走大量生命，他们确实开始有些担忧：我们的族群有一天会彻底消失吗？这已经是他们离“世界末日”最近的想法了。
No vision of apocalypse, right? Yeah, I mean, I noted it down when I read it. Those Aztecs who lived through the war with the Spaniards and then survived the first great epidemic of European diseases found to their surprise that the sun continued to rise and set and that they still had to face the rest of their lives. And I think that that's a perfect note on which to end, a kind of bittersweet note of kind of mingled despair and survival. So Camilla, thanks so much for coming on the show.
没有出现过任何关于世界末日的幻象，对吧？是的，我的意思是，我在阅读时特意记下了这一点：那些经历过与西班牙人战争、又在第一波欧洲疾病大流行中幸存下来的阿兹特克人，惊讶地发现太阳依然在升起和落下，他们依然不得不去面对余下的生活。我认为这为本期节目画上了一个完美的句号，这是一种苦乐参半的基调，交织着绝望与求生的意志。所以，卡米拉，非常感谢你来到我们的节目。
Really, really appreciate it. Yeah, it's been fascinating. Thank you so much. For listeners, Camilla's book is The Fifth Son, A New History of the Aztecs. Honestly, one of the most fascinating, eye-opening, moving history books I've read. Can't recommend it highly enough. So thank you very much for listening. Thank you.
真的非常、非常感激。是的，这段经历太迷人了。非常感谢你。对于听众朋友们，卡米拉的书是《第五个太阳：阿兹特克新史》（The Fifth Son, A New History of the Aztecs）。老实说，这是我读过的最迷人、最开阔眼界、最感人的历史书之一。强烈向大家推荐。非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、享受无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。